Texas senator Ted Cruz senator my
expectations out of whack
Shawn you're exactly right your
expectations are what the American
people are rightly demanding we need to
get the job done we've got a mandate an
overwhelming victory from the voters in
November they've given us a Republican
president Republican heads of every
agency and Republican majorities in both
houses of Congress we don't have any
more excuses we need to get the job done
and the big four that we promised the
American people is repeal the train
wreck that is Obamacare we've got to get
that done major tax cuts major tax
reform we've got to get that done
regulatory reform getting Washington off
the backs of small businesses and job
creators and confirming
constitutionalists to the US Supreme
Court in the federal courts if we do
those four this could be the most
productive Congress in decades and if we
don't do any of them it will be a
heartbreaking missed opportunity listen
I see that your plan and the president's
plan are almost identical I can live
with either one and the American people
would benefit you add energy
independence to that you're right of
some justices you build 400 miles 300
miles of the wall and you show you
getting that job done and Republicans
can have the best year they ever dreamed
of in 2018 but it's not happening and I
do you agree that that the Republicans
especially in the Senate have pushed the
president into the arms of the Democrats
now and he's got to look for
alternatives well look I think the
president is frustrated I think the
American people are frustrated because
we're not getting the job done on Obama
care we came one vote short it was
beyond it may make your head explode but
let me tell you on Obamacare we're going
to get the job done I believe failure is
not an option I've told Mitch McConnell
I've told other senators we need to keep
at it till we honor that promise and and
and critically we lower premiums and
give people more choices more options
put you in charge of your health care on
tax reform we got to do it and what the
president just said that you aired
earlier on the show simple and fair put
it on a postcard get rid of those nine
billion hours that we waste filling out
forms paying
Countians paying lawyers make it simple
fare and focus on jobs let small
businesses create more jobs and raise
wages if we get the economy booming we
cut taxes repeal Obamacare will have a
terrific election in 2018 if we don't
get any of it done we'll have a terrible
election in 2018 senator here's your
plan now it's what I've been saying
it's what the president is saying it's
simple give the middle class a tax cut
corporate tax cuts or patreon file out a
postcard I agree with you 100% and you
add that to energy jobs and you've got
millions of Americans now working and
you got money flowing into Washington
you guys a lot more money than you ever
dreamed of and Newt Gingrich told me he
thinks it's about a 50% shot we get that
done if those aren't great odds to me
well and let me emphasize a couple of
points from from the tax speech I gave
today number one the president said
today he wants a big big tax cut there's
some Republicans in Congress that are
talking about making tax reform revenue
neutral revenue neutral means they're
not cutting taxes they're just moving
money around from one bucket to another
we don't need revenue neutral we need a
big tax cut on you on families who are
struggling on small businesses we need a
Reagan s tax cut that unleashes
incredible growth and I laid out today
how we do it we do that under the budget
rules by having a 30 year budget window
which means we can have a big tax cut
that isn't revenue neutral that lasts
for 30 years and unleashes booming
growth let me make a second point last
which is something I called for today
which is total expensing immediate
expensing of capital expenditures what
that does if you're a farmer
it lets you buy a new tractor if you're
a steel worker it lets the company
invest in a new steel factory if you're
a truck driver it lets you buy a new
truck we care about jobs here in America
Main Street jobs manufacturing jobs
union jobs blue-collar jobs immediate
expensing unleashes incredible growth I
think that's a very important part of
tax cuts and tax reforms that we're
pushing forward senator you mentioned
that you
you still think the windows open on
healthcare one of the proposals and as a
conservative I always kind of liked the
idea sending stuff back to the states
Lindsey Graham has that proposal
I talked to Dave brat and I talked to
mark meadows they support it but they
said the devil is in the details sure
something that could work is that maybe
the alternative maybe you get it done by
the 30th used in reconciliation
well considering reconciliation I think
Lindsey Graham's proposal could easily
be part of the solution I am a big big
believer in federalism sending things to
the states and powering the states you
know that's something if Lindsey's
proposal brings a few moderates on board
great and and let different states have
different approaches Letta John Kasich
in Ohio have one approach and let a
conservative like Greg Abbott and Texas
have a different approach that's why
we've got 50 steps slowly and and that's
probably to tax on Obamacare you know I
think where senator I want to say one
last thing I don't I'm really like I
can't tell you that the type of feedback
I'm getting from my audience and radio
and TV they are me livid they're
apoplectic and I will say this you on
health care you are keep saying on the
economy keep your promises the freedom
caucus is working day and night with you
and and together to keep their promises
if these guys don't wake up you're the
only few people I trust in Washington
now it's really despicable well Shawn
the role I'm trying to play is do
everything I can to help and encourage
the President to go in a positive
direction not a negative direction and
to bring Republicans together talking to
conservatives and moderates and
leadership and the president of the
administration saying everyone look if
we do our job just keep our word the
economy booms we see more jobs and
that's a win-win for everyone
why does it have to be so hard senator I
do appreciate you keeping your promises
it means a lot to us thank you